i have to say first of all the last time
i talked to you
there was this whole i don't want to be
the face of the first marvel franchise
that might
fail
[Laughter]
actors commercials in my future
hey you never know man we you never know
i was i was very concerned about the
idea of
being the first bombing marvel uh
franchise
[Music]
we can say now that is not the case
do you feel some kind of way though with
the overwhelming like
love that this franchise has gotten
first of all i wish i was watching every
episode with you i was talking back to
the tv scream and yelling i have things
to say
nah it's uh it's funny because i've
watched all the episodes with my sons
and um you know their reactions were so
funny man and and i never
i became a spectator i became an
audience member and was able to like let
go of it and watch it with them
so it was a lot of fun i had never had
the experience of just
sitting back and enjoying it as a parent
instead of an actor in the show so uh
the the overwhelming appreciation and
love
is something i expected uh because i'm a
cup half full kind of guy
yeah and just because there's one
annoying person on the internet that
doesn't cancel out the millions of good
people
right on the internet so i just look at
it that way
the only power i have is that i believe
we can do better
we can't demand that people step up and
we don't meet them halfway
well the internet seem to be very happy
but i wonder i wonder you know you said
you watched it with your sons which i
think is interesting because two then
they get this vision
of a black captain america not just dad
but a black captain america how did that
sit with them and did it
like really resonate with them and how
do you how do you feel about now
being the face and kind of the role
model for a lot of other brown
kids that are gonna look at you and
think wow
well it's it's funny because my little
ones they um
looked at it and we're all sitting in
the living room like i make my popcorn
and my gourmet popcorn and we're eating
the popcorn
and they're looking at the screen they
look at me once the popcorn is gone
they look at the screen they're like dad
that guy looks just like you
i'm like i know and
the five-year-old goes he sounds like
you too
so the you know the older two are like i
can't believe these dudes aren't getting
it but they can't
they can't put together that i'm on tv
and on the couch at the same time
so the little one goes you know dad you
could be captain america
i was like thanks man i appreciate it
well you know people are gonna say that
you know there's to be the comparisons
made so what do you think the biggest
difference going forward
um of chris's cap and your chapters um
you know i think uh what was interesting
with chris's cap
and what chris evans was able to do with
that character was really bring
a level of strength and confidence to
him he really
brought an even killed well-rounded
three-dimensional character
i think sam wilson because he was a
counselor uh
of vets because of his background with
his family
uh and a lot of people don't realize sam
wilson is the only superhero who has no
superpowers
he's just a regular guy who went for a
jog and became an avenger
right so you know he comes from a place
of
uh humanity and humility you know it's
not so much him just going through
and tearing stuff up you know it's more
so much about the
the cerebral introspective idea of how
do you handle a problem because he was a
counselor
right you know so he still got them
hands though
but he's not a superhero he's a regular
guy
you know there was a certain aspect of
um let's say his physique i guess we
could say
that that was highlighted
there was even a quote about it in
in-game that is america's ass
that's america's ass so if we're
saying now any suggestions about what uh
you know your cat highlight
should be in your uniform well
you know i i don't i i would say
um i'm a i'm i'm more of a um
a beefier guy than chris chris
is you know contained he's compact i'm
more
robust so uh you know i think i think
people won't be disappointed with around
brown so
cap cakes and round brown i love it
i love it
this final title card was captain
america
and the winter soldier yeah people think
this is going to be the title of season
two is there validity to that is there a
plan in place
uh i don't know i haven't heard anything
i haven't no one's called me
um so you're capable of america
nobody called i'm like my phone work dog
i pay i pay my bill every month
so uh i don't i don't know i don't know
what's going on they always have some
kind of plan
uh but there's like 30 million projects
you know
in production right now so i just wait
for the phone call from
kevin and nate to tell me what i'm doing
now is that the marvel answer because
you want to stay captain america or is
that the real deal that you really don't
know
wait miss turner is that the question
with you trying to get me fired is that
what you're saying
got it i mean literally it's been three
days
and you're trying to get me fired three
days i'm gonna leave it alone i like
black after work
i want you to stay in your job but what
does this mean for bucky then if that is
you know the title card was captain
america the winter soldier what does
this mean for
bucky's story going forward i don't know
i mean look
sebastian's one of my dear friends uh i
think it's obvious that we work
extremely well together so the idea
of you know us being a duo
it ain't that bad of a thing you know i
think everybody get what they want you
know you
you know you get the glaze and you get
the chocolate glaze you know so it's
like
everybody get the donut they want so i
think we all be happy with that
their story to be told you just flirt
with your sister i want that to happen i
know i'm like what are we doing right
now
i'm backing
[Music]
well these boots are not made for
walking
can we talk really quick about julia
louis-dreyfus first of all thank you
lord for bringing her to tomorrow
family i know that she was supposed to
debut in black widow
and they kept it under like the cloak
of secrecy for sure um
was this the first time you saw them
because she she really was under a cloak
like a big giant
was this the first time you saw them do
something like that to keep
keep a secret usually when we're on set
we're all cloaked and
all that stuff uh julia louise dreifus
was kind of like a surprise to everybody
uh we got to set one day and it was just
whispers like yo you know who's here
today i'm like who's here
who what's going on who's this person
you know and she was really sweet
she played the game well came on set and
was just like
a regular actress that was the first
time i've seen them
like get somebody who is
amazing like that and they show like
like you know nobody expected that we
knew because we were on set
and you know she she uh played the game
really well
well i need more val i need to know
what's happening i'm ready
for it i'm ready she's just so good
though it's like
she's so sassy but in a nice way